[Music]
[Applause]
Doc Rivers he'll be on the call Celtics
and the Knicks tonight oh you got to
dust off the microphone you remember how
to do this doc but I don't I don't know
Dan I'm looking at the picture behind
you you got I think that's Al Michaels
if I'm not if my eyes are are still
right uh yeah so yeah I'm gonna try to
dust them off and um at least I'm not
talking about you know that golf or
something I don't know you know so let's
let's hope it all works out okay are you
a coach when you're a commentator are
you a former player when you're a
commentator are you a fan when you're a
commentator well hope I'm all three you
know it it's interesting uh when I first
did this I think Dan you were 11 with my
first broadcast uh I sat next to Vern
lanquist and he told me listen son uh
you can do this a lot of ways uh the way
I would do it I would celebrate the game
uh I would make sure everyone leaves the
game happier with knowledge and they
enjoy it so that's what I'm going to try
to do how's the voice because usually
when I talk to you you got your coach
voice I I worry about that voice of
yours oh I do too uh you know it's funny
uh my daughter played me a
clip um a year before I took my coaching
job and that was a different voice wow
so uh I guess it's if you had you know I
don't know 20 kids um you know at a at a
camp every day where the Acoustics were
awful and you did it for 24 years this
is what would happen to your
boys have you gone to see somebody oh I
have I um actually when I was with the
Celtics um I had a pup on my vocal cord
um had to get it removed which is scary
you've heard those stories where you
know any bad incision on that your
voiceless uh other than that it's just
my voice it's just tibo's voice it's you
know it's a lot of screaming and lot
Arenas and it happens uh it does feel
stronger now uh but this is going to be
my voice for the rest of my life Bry uh
does an impersonation of you is it is it
okay I mean yes okay I've heard a lot of
okay all right I want you to judge it
all right fritzy um how about you play
Doc Rivers and I'm going toh interview
you after a big win and uh uh hey coach
congratulations how did you do it you
know Dan we played within ourselves I
told the guys before we took the court
forget about the name on the back of
your jersey it's only about what's on
the front it was our first team effort
in a while I don't see guys running over
to the scores table with a video board
looking for that startat line we went
big we went small I'm proud of the guys
we got to show up a couple of things all
right thanks Sam all hey hey that's
that's really good slow toate it slow it
down a little bit okay other than that
it's perfect that was that was really
good that's that's better than Jamie
Fox's impersonation that's terrific
fritzy's kind of morphed into Kevin
Harland there too a little bit Yeah Yeah
fritzy does a great Kevin harand the
nuggets have gone up 8 to six and the
Oklahoma City Thunder want to talk about
it a 70 run this is the NBA on TNT
you know Kevin is is a good friend I did
games with Kevin and I remember one of
his first games and now I'm you know a
season bet with return it my third year
and it was a Houston Rockets game it was
the literally and I'm not exact it was
the third play of the game and Kevin
goes big you know and he looks at me and
he says too
early maybe a little bit all right um
how would you use Victor W bayama how
how much playing time would you give him
if you were coaching him you know what's
surprising is all the talk about playing
time with him you know um I think you're
just gonna play him uh they see him
every day you know um I wouldn't worry
about the minutes with him early I've
never heard that much talk with rookies
maybe because of Zion people are
concerned or because of his body type
you know CAD gets injured last year I
think pop is just gonna play him um you
know 30 35 minutes a night uh if he's
healthy uh but man I got to tell you Dan
um he looks special like special special
to me uh in everything that I see and
you know forget the talent and all that
what I see that I like the most is he
has this um this competitive thing in
him that you can actually see you saw it
when they played Oklahoma you saw it
after the first bad game in the summer
league in that second game he he's done
it he did it a bunch last year too he's
played with grown men already uh in his
life not grown men this talented um yeah
I I just think they're not going to
worry about it if something tells them
to they will but I don't think that's
the game plan it's wearing about minutes
with him talking to Doc Rivers he'll be
on the call for the mothership Celtics
in the Knicks tonight at 7 Eastern with
Mike Breen also he'll be working Friday
night Warriors and the Kings at 10
Eastern explain to me how
joic does
this boy it's hard you know um I made a
comment like three or four years ago
like me this at the time you remember
when his body didn't look as good as it
looks now I was like this big overweight
uh bartender is destroying us he's
destroying us uh and and and that's how
he looked and you watch him play Dan
it's absolutely beautiful uh in almost
everything he does his passing uh his
shots um his shot making ability doesn't
get enough play you know obviously he
can make the three you know he has great
post move but his unorthodox little flip
shots in traffic through contact uh and
you and we're talking all that and then
you forget the best part of his game in
his passing he can he's one of those
guys Magic Johnson type that he makes
his whole team better uh immediately
everybody that plays on the floor I
would be S I would be scared if I was a
GM to sign a player from the Denver
Nuggets because you're really like he
makes them that much better and so
you're trying to evaluate well if we
take him will this guy be that good
when's the last time you were watching a
game as a player or a coach and you
found yourself just watching the game
not playing in the game or coaching in
the game you were admiring something
that you were
seeing wow that's a that's a great
question uh it's been a long time I I'll
tell you that because once you once you
coach you you've interviewed a million
coaches you never watch the game as just
the game anymore um I'm watching the
game last night and um Golden State I
thought ran a terrific play and the next
thing you know I'm jotting it down and
trying to figure out um you know
different ways to stop it different ways
to run if you're on offense um you know
you see things a lot uh in games you
know and so I think from being a player
but more from being a coach it's just
hard to watch it that way but you still
enjoy it you enjoy beautiful basketball
probably more now but you didn't find
yourself as a player going damn that's
impressive like watching it that way
yeah I did absolutely you know when
you're playing guys you know I did guard
Michael and there were times I was
running down the court shaking my head
thinking damn that's
impressive yeah yeah so you do and even
as a as a coach there's times where
especially when guys do it on your team
but even when guys on the other team
you're just so impressed by some of
these guys and the way they play yeah
that absolutely still crosses your mind
if a GM called you to get your opinion
on James Harden you would say what
that's the maybe the best question
someone's asked me um he went playing
right and if you watch I tell everyone
go back to the first half of last year
yeah where where he gave himself to the
team Dan we were the best team in IND
for a 10 20 game stretch and it was you
know obviously we have Joel and tyres
and Tobias but we were because James was
being a point guard um you know it's
funny um a coach called me and said I
never thought anyone can get him to do
that and he did you know for short term
so that's what I would tell them and if
you can keep him in that and and not
want to chase numbers or or wed to score
the thirst of scoring um then you you
have a terrific player yeah but what
changed though doc what changed he was
playing perfectly I thought for you guys
yeah he really was I I would say not
making the All-Star team really bothered
him um and I thought that that
was egregious you know the coaches just
didn't put him on you know he was only
leading the league in scoring earning
assists um he was having his best
three-point percentage shooting uh year
of his career he was averaging plus 20
and the coaches didn't put him on the
All-Star team and he would never say
this but in my my gut I thought it
changed almost immediately remember
about a game or two after that he called
me and said hey I want to start coming
and playing with the second unit more um
and I know exactly what that means uh
more shots more shots I want to go back
to attack it in playing and you know we
had our ups and downs from that point on
uh you know it was funny about our
relationship it was an honest one I'll
tell you that it's probably why I'm
doing
TV but you have to be honest as a coach
and you have to you have to just keep
selling it like listen when you do this
it may not be the best or most fun for
you but we are a better team and I and I
never relented on that and I I thought
he appreciated that even even at the
very end but more frustrating Harden or
Ben
Simmons oh um I you know that's a good
one I would say maybe James only because
James
can't you know like when he did we were
great Ben was frustrated in a whole
different way you know um you know just
the mental part the health part um the
injury part um you
know just the work ethic part I mean all
those things and so that was a different
type of frustration I didn't I didn't
have the frustration with Ben thinking
if Ben did this we can win it but I
surely had that with James and so
because I'm in it to win it I think
maybe that would be more frustrating for
you plus it must be tough to coach
somebody that you don't know if they
love basketball certain guys are good at
sports you got to love basketball and I
wondered if Ben loved basketball or he
was just good at B
basketball yeah I would say I I agree
with that uh there were times um like
and that's through the league you know
that like if you don't love the game um
you could only be good at it and I've
always said this uh the playoff always
exposes guys who really loveing uh
because the pressure of the playoffs uh
and the intensity of the games if you
don't absolutely love it it will eat you
up it does and you can see it every year
with certain guys and so um yeah I would
say you're right on that like that that
I always look at Ben though and this is
the coach part that probably does us all
in Dan like every coach if the if word
like man I tell you if he loved it or if
if I could get him to play this way like
he is a freak of nature athletically
bodywise
visionwise uh but the rest of the part
wasn't there welcome back to the
broadcasting Community doc are you are
you here for good or is this a just a
temporary job I I don't even know the
answer to that uh yet Dan uh right now I
would say I feel like it's something
that I want to just do I'm having the
most fun that I've had in a long time
I'm not getting cause at three in the
morning um you know so it's a pretty
good life so I'm planning on staying
there good to talk to you we'll be uh
listening tonight watching uh thanks for
joining us doc oh always thank you
that's Doc Rivers he is uh going to be
on the call tonight Celtics Knicks with
the uh great Mike Breen and then
Warriors Kings Friday night both of
those games will be on the Mother Ship
some very revealing stuff we'll discuss
that when we return plus fritzy's
tribute song to the Arizona Diamondbacks